من ايذاء النفس الى الترويج لعدات تغذيه
خطيره تيك توك يعرض محتوى ضارا في غضون
دقائق قليله من انشاء حساب على المنصه
دراسه جديده نشرها مركز مكافحه الكراهيه
الرقمي في بريطانيا بعد تعاون باحثين من
عده دول وامريكا واستراليا وكندا انشا
حسابات الاختبار خوارزميات تيك توك وحددوا
السن عند 13 عاما وهو اقل عمر لانشاء حساب
اقتضى تجربه توقف لفتره وجيزه وتسجيل
الاعجاب لمحتوى يدور حول صوره الجسد
والصحه العقليه وجاء في النتائج ان
التطبيقه اوصى بمقاطع فيديو حول تلك
الموضوعات كل 39 ثانيه خلال نصف ساعه ومن
التصفح في حسب التجربه وباختصار احتجاج
تيك توك لثلاث دقائق فقط اقل من انشاء
حساب جديد قبل عرض محتوى يتعلق بالانتحار
ونحو خمس دقائق فقط لاقتراحي مقطع يروج
لاضطرابات لك
تم تك توك للرد على الدراسه ولتجربه التي
كشفت عن ترويج المنصه لمحتويات مضره للصحه
العقليه من اداء للنفس او الترويج لعادات
غذائيه سلبيه متحدث باسم من سيعتقدون
التجربه غير دقيقه لان الحسابات الوهميه
التي شاركت محدوده كان 30 دقيقه ليست
كافيه للحكم على خوارزميات الموقع
تيك توك يقول ان مركز مكافحه كراهيه رقمي
لم يميز في تجربته بين مقاطع الفيديو
الايجابيه والسلبيه في مواضيع معينه على
سبيل المثال هناك من من مقاطع عن اضطرابات
الاكل لكن هناك من يشارك تجوبته في
التعافي منها وليس الترويش اليها تيك توك
تقول انها تواصل ايضا حمايه جديده
لمستخدمها منها مجموعه من ادوات الرقابه
الابويه وتحديث فترات زمنيه لتصفح ومنع
كلمه معينه من اظهار اين نتائج في محرك
البحث اخيرا تقول المنصه انها ازالت اكثر
من
93% من المقاطع المتعلقه الى النفس او
الاتحاد في الفتره بين ابريل الى يونيو
الماضيه اي قبل ان يشاهدها اي شخص
[موسيقى]
المزيد انضم الينا من الكويت
اذا النفس ما هي المعايير التي تعطي هكذا
دراسه مش دقيقه
اول شيء صباح الخير نادين صباح الخير سهام
صباح الخير لكل المشاهدين
فعلا عم تكتب بس ما فينا نعمل دراسه انك
على خوارزميات يلي ما عندنا اقصص عليها
وما بنعرف بتشتغل بنتكل بس على نفتح ثمان
حسابات مقسمه الحسابين باربع دول وعلى
فتره كثير قصيره ونجي نقول انه هذه دراسه
علميه هاي دراسه
بدنا نفكر فيها بطريقه منطقيه هذه امريكي
يعني دايما في مساله الغوريزم في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي وخصوصا تيك توك يعني
وتعقب كل مستخدم وفقه ما يشاهد وهكذا لكن
التعريف بشكل عام عن الخوارزميات التي
يعمل بها تيك توك وغيرها من المنصات ما هو
هو بكل بساطه نحن اذا اول ما بلشت المواقع
الالكترونيه
بس بلشت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي صار
المحتوى يعني كلنا عندنا مثلا تيك توك او
انستغرام او فيسبوك بس كل شخص بيفوت على
هذه المواقع بيشوف محتوى متخصص فيه بناء
على اعجابته
وهذا المواضيع مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مش
بس بتتابع المتصفحين بس عبر المواقع بتاع
سنه
شو نوع الاكل
التواصل الاجتماعي على الثاني
مع الوقت
صراحه هذا السؤال الاهم والاصعب الاكيد ما
في ولا اي موقع من مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي او غيره بيقدر يعمل ميه بالميه
تكون او اداره المحتوى يعني شفنا بالتقرير
مثل حضرتك ذكرتهم على 93% من المحتوى
السيء بس هذا 7% من كميات المحتوى الموجود
يللي خارج عن السيطره عليه خاصه
في عندهم اكثر من 200 لخمه وبيستخدموا على
الفيسبوك هم بيقدر يصلوا بس على 170 الاخر
عندك مشاكل اللغه مثلا اللغه العربيه
بلبنان غير مصر غير الخليج غير غيره بكل
دول العالم في عندك عده لغات همم
كثير صعب والاصعب بعد انه تيك توك من
المنصات اللي كثير بتتكل على اللايف على
الواحده والمباشر يا اللي ولا ممكن يقدر
الواحد طيب حتى وقالوا لهم بيقدر يسيطر
على الخوارزميات طب لماذا لا يستطيعون وضع
احد لمعاقبه المنصه مثلا اقل له حصلت كثير
من التحديات مات بسببها اطفال لا يتم
توجيه اتهام بشكل مباشر بالدرجه الاولى
ومعاقبه المنصه لماذا حتى الان
للاسف هذا الموضوع صحيح
من ضمننا والشيعه الموت هي اللي صار عده
اطفال ميت من وراء هذا بشكل كبير كبيره بس
دايما ان احنا نطلع انه موضوع الثبات وضع
عقوبات على منصته هذا او يقطع اما نشوف
عقوبات ماليا وضعت على فيسبوك انستغرام
تيك توك وغيره بسلمت او الماكس معه بيكون
هو عقوبات ماليه كثير بتاثر على المناصات
مع كل ارباحها الي عملها لانه بالنهايه في
سياسيات دول يعني شفنا رئيس الامريكي
الدولار قبل من ولايته جنى بيوقف همم تيك
توك امريكا
يوصل الى محل يوقف وهذا المنصات عن العمل
بنشكرك جزيل الشكر من الكويت رولون ابي
نجم مستشار فيه انو تكنولوجيا المعلومات
والتحول الرقمي شكرا لك